et si moi je peux le réseau suite johan
20 ans est étudiant en licence
d'économie gestion finance
il vient postulé pour un poste en caisse
restauration au zoo de thoiry
comme lui ils étaient plusieurs
étudiants à vouloir trouver un emploi
notamment pour la période estivale
je venu pour trouver un travail pour
l'été quoi pour essayer de travailler un
peu en ce moment je suis au chômage et
on est sûr locales et m'ont dit de venir
ici pour chercher quelque chose
les chés étudiants et ça m'arrange pour
mes études mois déjà de base quand
j'étais petit je voulais faire
vétérinaire après les études étaient
trop longues et
et là j'ai vu que bas qu'ils ont
embauché bas je suis venu comme j'aime
bien tout ce qui est un hymne au lieu de
ça on déjeune parfois familiers du zoo
la direction propose différents contrats
pour travailler le week-end les vacances
uniquement le dimanche ou en semaine des
postes saisonniers et flexible pour le
service d'entretien la caisse ou la
restauration et la possibilité de
choisir parmi plusieurs candidats le but
de ce forum c'était de recevoir un
maximum de gens de collecter des cv et
de ne pas dire tout de suite on a besoin
de vous la semaine prochaine mais
peut-être dans un mois même cet été
moi j'espère avoir des étudiants qui
nous disent en juillet-août je suis
dispo ça sera bien plus facile pour
anticiper tout au long de l'année
l'effectif du parc est composé de 58
employés durant la haute saison ils sont
près de 90 personnes a travaillé dans le
zoo